hello good morning my name is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize in Stockholm yeah
very good I already talked some of your
with your colleagues this morning well
first of all congratulations on the
award another penguin
it must be very special in particular
because you came up with the idea of
this detector well be careful with that
other people also had sort of detectors
that don't be careful with that I mean
in fact there was a group in Russia and
in 1962 Ashton Stein and push hobbits I
can't pronounce it for you well they
wrote a little paper in a Russian
Journal which none of us knew about that
not to do this do it by the
interferometry so much but that's a used
light as a way of doing this and then it
turns out you're Webber which are
unbeknownst to us but also with your
Webber who was sort of the way first
person to start thinking about this with
his Webber balls so Webber yellow the
Webber bar but and at the end of the
Webber bars he also has some notes about
that maybe we should do this with with
with interferometry the love the whole
world tried to reproduce the Webber
experiments I don't know if you you're
probably young too young to know that
but but the thing is that in 60 we've
ever made his big announcement in 69 and
where he showed that he had within three
bars he had seen gravitational ways and
then that got virtually everybody in the
well of many many groups both in Europe
and Asia and in the United States try to
reproduce this and - everybody's
disappointment nobody saw the same thing
that Joe did Joe whoever did and the way
it happened in my life as I was teaching
a course in general relativity in the
middle of that epoch in sort of 1967 and
I couldn't explain the way a Weber barb
worked at it mostly because I just
didn't know enough okay but it it was
that I thought there would be an easier
way to explain well how a gravitational
wave interacts with matter if one just
looked at the most primitive thing of
all 3d floating masses
yes out in space and look at how the
space between them changed because of a
gravitational wave coming between them
and I gave that as a problem in the
course you know and the kids in this
course did it because it's a fairly
straightforward calculation and that was
sort of 67 and by the about 70 to 71 it
turned out that many people were not
seeing I mean it was already quite clear
that the bar to technique and and
Weber's experiments were not being seen
by others and so I spent a summer
thinking about maybe this idea that I
gave is a exercise in a course would be
a nice way to try to do this because it
was so easy to understand it and that
then turned into like oh but other
people had thought of it I didn't know
that nevertheless a journey from the
early 70s to now the sense of
achievement and excitement oh no no I
mean look the other thing I'll be
letting has nothing to with pride it has
to do what I did something which others
didn't do I actually do the calculation
of what might be all the things that get
in the way of being able to do it which
actually turned out to be very useful
you know the different noises that would
make it impossible to see it you are
possible to see it you had to solve a
whole set of problems and and that was
my contribution to it in the early days
well that's it I mean it's quite
mind-boggling to think of how precise
this piece of equipment is yeah that's
true and it took that's what took by the
way I think the easiest way to say it is
that the concept is very straightforward
you measure the time it takes light to
go between two orthogonal directions in
the gravitational wave and and you go
and you measure that time very carefully
and that ideas sort of tripping I mean
most people who know a little bit of
physics can make that calculation on the
other hand what happens to make it
actually happen because the sizes of
things are so small and I think the
easiest way to say it
are you familiar with the exponential
notation can I use that you can yes yeah
well okay I think the best way of saying
it is this way there are two factors of
10 to the 12 that had to be solved one
of them was that the light wavelength
itself is ten to the minus six meters
and so you had to devise a way to make
light which has
wavelength of 10 to minus 6 to go to be
good enough so you could measure 10 to
minus 18 meters and that is a factor of
10 to the 12 and that was not the
hardest problem but that was one of the
major problems between let's say 1972 to
1982 2015 but the other one is another
factor of 10 to the 12 which is just as
serious and that's much harder to solve
and that's what longer and that that
took more effort and that was that you
even though you may have this wonderful
method of now breaking up a light fringe
so you could do a part in 10 to the 12
of it you still don't know that the
thing that you're measuring is not being
pushed around by forces that make it
move much much more that are not
gravitational that are not gravitational
waves but others forces like thermal
noise or seismic motion of God knows all
the different things that can that
happen in the world that you were not
being at that same mirror that you're
looking at is not being pushed around by
by things that make it move more than 10
to minus 18 meters and that is another
factors 10 to the 12 about because it
turns out the ground motion it's about a
few micron 10 minus 6 meters again so
you have to devise a wonderful way to
get rid of the ground motion and then
get rid of the thermal noise and now
it's video at the point where we were
worrying about the quantum noise so but
it was all pretty well organized
I mean intense that people knew what the
problems would be it's just a matter it
takes time to do a thing like that the
contrast between the my new precision to
make the measurement and the size of the
actual gravitational wave but it tells
you is something really interesting it
tells you that space is very very stiff
to distortion you know it's you know the
Einstein waves can be thought of as a
distortion of space and time but way we
see it we see it as a distortion of
space and is it space is enormous least
if you can't squish it we can't change
its dimensions so easily and it turns
out that I think the easiest way to see
that or say it is that it's I'll give
you an example so that you can use it or
think about it if you put this whole
thing that was detected you know back to
the first detection and put it not at
a billion years of light years away but
rather put it at the Sun the distance of
the Sun suppose the Sun had somehow put
out those gravitational waves all right
you would have had a motion at the earth
of a you know a motion of over a
kilometer of up about only ten minus six
tonymoly ten minus six meters no tiny
fact you could just about hear it in
your ear but the amount of power that
went to you through you is something
like 10 to the 24 watts per centimeter
squared huge in other words it's it's
you know the Sun puts out about 10 to
the 4 watts not into what that yeah yeah
in fact almost all we did translate that
in that initial paper into the amount of
power was sort of brighter than anything
in the universe but 50 times brighter
for the few moments in which that
gravitational wave was that was actually
you know traveling through you they say
it's an enormous lease this the system
just does not like to make you can't
distort space very much but you do get a
little bit and that's what we measure
that that is a really beautiful concept
to mention on this call thank you so
much we will hopefully discuss all these
things more when you come to Stockholm
you will be coming to stop coming this
of course I will yeah and I attend that
if you can manage it
I would like to and I man I prefer
really often to talk to high school
students I mean most because I think
they're the future for us and so if you
I know I have to give lectures I'm very
happy to do that and so on my colleagues
but if you think that there are some
high school students who would benefit
from understanding this a little better
that would I be very happy to do that we
will most certainly work to fill rooms
with high school students for you yeah
the great objective we very very much
look forward to welcome you to Stockholm
how do you how do you feel about the
coming day which will be completely
taken over by this today yeah yeah I
don't know I'm at home like there's
still not completely dressed I am now
but little but yes I I know that I have
to confront all my colleagues and it's a
charming thing to do it's just a little
awkward that's wrong good luck with
finishing getting dressed and we look
forward to meeting you in Stockholm in
distance yeah I'm very happy to come
I've been there once with
you gave a Nobel Prize to one of my
colleagues named John Mathur and George
Smoot of course because you you you also
worked on the coping oh yeah yeah we I
worked on that with them and I've been
there and it's it's really quite a
pleasure to come there okay well we
great look forward to meeting thank you
so much